[Musique]
l'histoire de la royal air force
la royal air force est née le 1er avril
1910 lorsque le royal fleig cops et le
royal naval air service fut réunis au
sein d'une même formation force au jour
de sa création l arf était au coeur
d'une période dramatique celle du plus
sanglant conflit de toute l'histoire de
la civilisation
depuis ce jour la rfa toujours été
totalement opérationnel sans
interruption cette histoire de la nrf et
celle d'hommes et de machines elle
s'étend de l'ère des pionniers et de
leur avion en bois et en toile jusqu'à
l'heure actuelle de la sophistication et
de l'informatique
mais ce qui prédomine dans cette
histoire c'est l'esprit combatif qui a
animé les hommes de l'air
les avions ne sont qu'une partie de
cette histoire
ils ne peuvent fonctionner sans l'homme
qui appuie sur le bouton ou bascule le
premier interrupteur
ce récit est celui de leur devoir de
leur courage et de leur abnégation mais
par dessus tout celui de leurs
sacrifices et c'est aussi celui de
nombreux triomphes sur les obstacles les
plus difficiles il y à un vieil adage
qui dit les vieux déclenché les guerres
les jeunes la faune des jeunes hommes et
femmes de la rs ont tout au long du
siècle
magnifiquement servi leur patrie
[Musique]
et
pendant la première guerre mondiale
l'utilisation d'avions comme arme a
rapidement pris de l'ampleur alors que
l'armée britannique était assez
sceptique à propos des 1er escadron du
royal flying corp se doutant de leur
efficacité au combat
leur valeur est vite devenue évidente en
le rfc et le rn as aller pris de
l'ampleur
compte tenu de leur développement futur
se posait le problème de leur
organisation
le ministère de la guerre et l'amirauté
pensée respectivement mérité la mainmise
sur l'aérien
ap le premier ministre dow jones en
décida différemment et s'inspira de
recommandations émises par une source
impartiale et son choix fut celui
édictées par l'africain du sud le
lieutenant général yann son rapport
d'août 1917 cette excuse me recommandait
la mise sur pied d'une organisation
indépendante avec un ministère de l'air
et un état-major atteint ce rapport fut
approuvée par le ministère de la guerre
un décret fut rédigée présenté devant le
parlement le 1er avril 1918 avec la
nomination du major général sur you run
chars comme premier chef d'état-major la
royal air force était né pendant les
sept derniers mois de la guerre la rfa
combattu avec acharnement principalement
contre les chasseurs les bombardiers
allemands en juin 1918 une force de
bombardements indépendante fut formé au
sein de l'aef pour lancer de nombreux
raids de bombardement stratégique à
longue distance
bien que ces attaques étaient
relativement légère par rapport aux
standards actuels elles permirent de
poser les bases de la doctrine que la
rfi utilisa pendant de nombreuses années
au moins de juillet l'essentiel de
l'offensive allemande avait été contenu
et quelques squadron de la rfm furent
déployés en italie afin d'épauler les
armes et qui affrontait les autrichiens
les alliés lancèrent une offensive
générale en septembre 1918 et les
ressources allemande presque épuisés et
les défense autrichienne affaibli la
reddition n'était plus qu'une question
de temps
les autrichiens en acceptant les termes
le 3 novembre
les allemands suivirent en signant
l'armistice le 11 novembre le carnage de
la grande guerre et est enfin terminé
à ce moment la puissance de la rs se
montait à environ vingt-cinq mille cinq
cents officiers et 264 milles hommes du
rang il y avait également 25 mille
femmes dans le corps féminin de la rfl
et squadron avait reçu 22 1500 avions
dont 3300 était encore sur le front et
plus de 100 dirigeable
[Musique]
c'est arsenal conséquent nécessaire en
temps de guerre ne pouvait plus être
maintenus en temps de paix dans la
dépression juste à la fin des combats la
plupart des squadron furent dissous les
hommes et les femmes furent démobilisés
et même le chef d'état-major ukraine
charles perdit son poste des milliers
d'avions furent détruits ou vendus
quand c'était possible pour être
reconvertir les fins civiles la force de
bombardements indépendante fut démantelé
les importants contrats avec les
constructeurs dénoncé de nombreuses
compagnies impliquées dans l'industrie
aéronautique durent faire face un futur
sombre allant de fermeture en
liquidation la force de première ligne
qui restait alors été divisés en trois
groupes séparés la zone nord la zone sud
la zone côtière le futur de la rfa en
tant que 3ème force militaire anglaise
était assombrie par des doutes il a
besoin d'un danger existait de voir les
rêves démanteler ces escadrons affecté à
l'armée ou à la navy ce fut winston
churchill un homme qui avait affirmé
publiquement il détestait la guerre
aérienne et les bombardement des
populations civiles qui sauva la r
il fut nommé secrétaire d'état à la
guerre et l'air en janvier 1919
et s'il montre assez irréfutables
qualités de visionnaire en invitant sur
ustream tarder à reprendre son poste de
chef d'état major commandant hautement
déterminée et avec un fort souci de
l'objectif lens a rapidement un plan
permettant aux structures de là et rêve
d'être permanente prenne garde
réinstaller à son poste réalisa
rapidement que l'intérêt et le soutien
du public était indispensable pour la
survie de la ra et faons temps de paix
dans un de ces coups d'éclat en matière
de relations publiques
il organisa le premier meeting aérien de
la rf le 3 juillet 1920
ce meeting ne pouvait pas mieux tomber
car l'intérêt du public pour l'aviation
n'avait jamais été aussi fort folco
kebron venait d'effectuer leur traversée
de l'atlantique avec escales sur un
dycker zemit la rfa vais enchaîner en
effectuant un aller retour sur le même
trajet avec un dirigeable
après quoi un équipage de quatre hommes
dans un wimille modifiée avait rejoint
l'australie depuis l'angleterre
le public s'est donc rendu au meeting de
hendon par milliers et fut stupéfait par
l'habileté des pilotes de la raf qui
enchaînait les séance d'acrobaties
aériennes de bombardement simuler ou de
vol en patrouille serré bref avait gagné
le coeur du public et le spectacle de
hendon devint un événement annuel avec
une foule grandissante d'édition en
édition avec un futur un peu plus
assurée trenchs ap pouvait dresser ses
plans à plus long terme entre 1927 et
rennes charles devint le tout premier
marshall de la r f 2 ans plus tard il
pris une retraite bien méritée ne
pouvait se permettre de se passer des
services d'un homme qu'il avait
construite à partir de rien ont pris
rapidement une résolution celle de
s'assurer de ces services jusqu'au on
décréta que les titulaires des plus
hauts grades il ne pouvait pas prendre
de véritables retraite mais demeurait
actif pour le reste de leur existence
la place de trenchs hard fut prise par
un de ses lieutenants sur johnson monde
mais son commandement fut court et sans
histoire en 1933 sur edouard ellington
le remplaça bien kennington n'eut pas le
charisme de trenchs hard
il a certainement joué un rôle clé dans
l'histoire de la rfa être un chef d'état
major briand qui préside à la révolution
technologique préparant la rfa la
seconde guerre mondiale
en 1934 les plans qui prévoyait une
force de 52 squadron n'avait pas encore
été complètement atteint car seulement
42 avaient été formés pour une force de
première ligne de 488 avions en dépit de
l'opposition de la chambre des lords le
gouvernement décida d'un programme
d'expansion là et rêve devait aussi vite
que possible
comptait soixante quinze escadrons
supplémentaires et dans les cinq années
suivantes atteindre 128 squadron cette
politique a été menée avec la conviction
que le bombardement aérien pouvait
gagner une guerre à lui seul et que la
grande bretagne devait être capables de
mener des attaques puissantes là et rêve
jusqu'à cette période était
principalement équipés de biplans les
militaires pensant qu'il était plus sûr
que les monoplan construit pour les
compagnies aériennes civiles
cependant sous le commandement
d'ellington la situation avait commencé
à changer et la rs commence à introduire
de nouveaux avions dans ses rangs semez
squadron prenait livraison d'avions plus
rapide et plus lourds tels que le
wellington le hansson wheatley le hamden
le lit saunders le blé l'hydravion
sunderland
le prototype du wellington fait son vol
inaugural en juin 1936 à partir de
lusine vickers à brooklands après trois
ans de mise au point par l'ingénieur
barre mme wallis
les commandes suivie rapidement et la
version marque un entrer en service en
décembre 1937
l'objectif de vie coeur c'était de
sortir un avion neuf chaque jour et
comme la demande augmentait de nouvelles
usines furent construites à chester et
blackpool permettant d'atteindre une
production de 180 avions par mois
pendant la guerre ce chiffre monte à 300
par mois au cours de la production des
modifications furent apportées et tout
au long de sa carrière le wellington
connue différentes versions
la motorisation niveau l'ua passant de
moteurs de 850 chevaux à des moteurs de
1600 chevaux permettant d'emporter une
charge de bong largement plus importante
le mark 1 avec un équipage de six hommes
vous l'êtes à 420 km heure à 15 mille
pieds sur 4800 km la première version de
bombardements en train en service en
octobre 1938 et fut livrée aux squadron
99-2000 drôle au déclenchement de la
guerre environ un an plus tard la rs
n'avait pas moins de six squadron de
wellington en moins de 24 heures
ils entrèrent en action lors de la
première attaque de la rff contre
l'allemagne
solide et fiable le wellington
affectueusement surnommé wing qui
étaient utilisés par les bombers les
costauds et transport commandes
utilisé sur tous les théâtres
d'opérations il était particulièrement
polyvalent et il était inégalable facile
à entretenir et disposant de bonnes
performances combinées avec la grande
solidité de sa structure géodétique de
wellington était très apprécié de ses
équipages en 1945 environ 11 1500 avions
avaient été construits mais bien avant
que le dernier ne sortent des usines
vickers le wimpy avait assuré sa place
parmi les grands avions de l'histoire de
la r f
[Musique]
l'état-major du beurre commandes a
décidé de lancer un raid massif de plus
de 1000 bombardier pour atteindre ce
chiffre
ils ont puisé dans les unités de seconde
ligne et donc on s'est retrouvé en
opération alors qu'on était encore en
unité d'entraînement
l'une des choses amusantes
c'était qu'il avait une bonne autonomie
ces moteurs était gourmand et les
réservoirs d'huile n'était pas suffisant
on avait donc des bidons d'huile dans le
fuselage est un des boulots de
l'opérateur radio était à certains
moments du vol de compléter les
réservoirs d'huile des moteurs pour ça
il avait une pompe manuelle dans le
fuselage et il devait descendre dans
l'obscurité pour l'atteindre inspiré pas
mal de chansons de bach
[Musique]
le bristol beinheim était apprécié par
ses équipages au moins autant que le
wellington
cet appareil révolutionnaire a été conçu
par l'ordre aux moeurs au début des
années 30 mais pas comme avions de
combat mais comme avion personnel ou
d'affaires à haute performance
quand la rfa pris livraison des
premières versions militaire en 1937 il
était alors le plus rapide et le plus
moderne des avions un service
deux ans plus tard au début de la guerre
plus d'un millier étaient en service ce
qui en faisait l'appareil le mieux
représenté dans l'arsenal anglais
principal avion de la force offensive
anglaise
le bombardier bimoteur devaient
supporter l'essentiel des premiers
combats mais la technologie aéronautique
était en pleine accélération dès le
début de la guerre le blenheim fut vie
totalement dominée par les chasseurs
allemands de ce fait les pertes des
plannings pendant les deux premières
années de la guerre furent simplement
effrayante souvent envoyés dans des
missions pour lesquelles leurs machines
étaient inadaptés les équipages de blé
name ont subi les pertes les plus
lourdes de tous les équipages de la rff
de la seconde guerre mondiale
nous avions confondu mais en dépit de
ces lourdes pertes le blé name conserver
la confiance de ses équipages et
continue à jouer courageusement son rôle
pas seulement comme bombardier mais
aussi comme chasseur effectuant ses
missions de jour comme de nuit les
exploits de cette machine élégante
furent nombreux et remarquable
il fut le premier avion britannique à
franchir la frontière allemande et à
effectuer la première attaque contre un
navire de guerre allemand
l'admiral scheer il fut le premier avion
à prendre part à une offensive aérienne
et le premier a mené une mission d'
intrusion nocturne le blé naïm
expérimental et premier développement
d'un radars aéroportés et emporta le
premier radar d'interception nocturne
opérationnel il coula le premier hub
haute et devint le seul avion de la rff
à servir sur tous les fronts dans tous
les commandements de la sève et en ce
qui concerne les équipages leur bravoure
pu sans égale mission après mission ils
portèrent la guerre chez l'ennemi dans
des missions à la limite suicidaire
comme le montre le nombre de victoria
cross décernés à des pilotes de blé name
plus nombreuses que celles décernées aux
pilotes de spitfire et uri caine réunis
d'aussi loin que je me souvienne
c'était le meilleur était tous les
équipages de blenheim vous le diront
c'était une machine absolument
formidable ryan est ravi
[Musique]
c'était un avion magnifique à piloter il
pouvait tourner dans un mouchoir de
poche et c'était vraiment utile surtout
quand vous aviez des avions ennemis à
vos trousses
deschodt son amende a été conçu en
réponse à une spécification du ministère
de l'air pour un monoplan quadrimoteur
indispensable pour remplacer en urgence
les avions de patrouille maritime
cing apport vieillissant il fit son
premier vol en octobre 1937 et fut
livrée à la rff moins d'un an plus tard
les squadron 230 à singapour et 210 à
pembroke dock furent les premières
unités à en prendre livraison
les premières réactions des équipages
furent l'étonnement devant la taille
incroyable et le fuselage spacieux
c'était quelque chose qu'il n'avait
encore jamais vu avec une envergure de
plus de 35 mètres et une longueur hors
tout de 28 m l'ange à mesure plus de 10
mètres de haut une fois sorti de l'eau
nous sommes dans l'homme marqué un grand
progrès par rapport à ses prédécesseurs
avec une vitesse maximum de 300 km/heure
il était plus rapide de 100
kilomètres/heure que le singapore et il
pouvait monter à plus de 1200 pieds par
minute pour un plafond pratique de vingt
mille pieds en 1939 la rfa en avait 40
ans services et alors que les hostilités
suivaient leur cours
le sunderland commencer les missions
pour lesquelles il est est idéalement
conçu les longues et ennuyeuses
patrouille maritime au dessus d'un océan
sans fin
le sunderland a été déclinée en cinq
versions différentes au long de sa
carrière dans la r f
il fut un des très rares avions à rester
en service tout au long de cette période
est le seul de la rfa exécuter les
missions en première ligne jusqu'à la
guerre de corée bien plus tard grâce à
sa conception solide et ses grandes
capacités d'emport mais aussi son
impressionnant armement autant offensif
que défensif
le sunderland n'avait aucun rival adoré
par ses équipages et hautement respecté
par l'ennemi
le sunderland est entré dans la légende
et de tous les hydravions a volé pour la
r f
il a sans doute été le meilleur donc
avec ces nouveaux avions à leur
disposition et des plans de réarmement
en pleine expansion ainsi que
l'ouverture de nouveaux aérodrome à
travers tout le pays
la rs ressemblait alors enfin à la force
qu'elle devait être pour en remontrer à
ses éventuels agresseurs
pour les squadron de chasse il y avait
peu de changements mais ce raid war
ellington toujours en avance sur son
temps décida que les biplans gloucester
gauntlet et gladiator devait être
remplacé ellington était inquiet à
propos de la situation en europe
hitler avait pris le pouvoir en
allemagne et en dépit du traité de
versailles avait formé la luftwaffe avec
un célèbre pilote de la première guerre
mondiale à sa tête
hermann goering la luftwaffe possédait
1800 avions linton pris la tête d'une
équipe qui publia 3 spécifications
majeur pour les futurs avions de la rff
qu'elle considérait comme vitaux si la
herray voulait jouer un rôle dans la
guerre qui semblait déjà inévitable
la première spécification concernait un
chasseur rapide et manoeuvres en pouvant
emporter un minimum de huit
mitrailleuses c'est à dire le double des
biplans d'alors deux constructeurs
répondirent à cette spécification de
nouveaux avions utilisé le moteur merlin
et à l'est dans les années suivantes
écrire leur propre chapitre dans
l'histoire de la f1 au coeur produisit
le riz khan qui entra en service en 1937
supermarine spitfire bientôt légendaire
qui entra en service l'année suivante
le rockeur ricaine conçu par sidney cam
fut le premier chasseur monoplan de la
rff et le premier avion de combat
capables de dépasser 480 km heure en
palier
mais ce que le week-end rendait au
spitfire en terme de vitesse il le gagne
en polyvalence le riz khan était la
synthèse de nombreuses années de
conception de chasseurs biplan rapporté
à une formule plus moderne un compromis
de construction traditionnelle et de
nouveaux équipements
alors que le spitfire conçu par angie
mitchell était à la fois d'une
conception inspiré et l' aboutissement
d'un lent processus d'évolution qui
remontait au super marine ssb qui avait
remporté la coupe ce n'est des rebbah tu
le record de vitesse
ces deux avions connu de nombreuses
évolutions et variantes pendant leur
carrière opérationnelle dont pas moins
de 40 pour le spitz
ces deux avions partagé le même moteur
rolls royce merlin il montrait de
formidables capacités et quel que soit
le rôle et la mission qu'on leur
confiait il s'en montrer digne
bien sûr les pilotes avaient leurs
préférences mais ce qui était vraiment
évident avant et pendant la guerre était
qu'à partir du moment où ces deux avions
étaient entrés en service la rs
possédait deux avions de combats qu'ils
pouvaient apporter leur contribution
dans n'importe quel conflit
la seconde des trois spécifications de
l'équipe d'ellington concernait le
développement d'un bombardier lourd
quadrimoteur pouvant emporter une charge
de bombes largement plus lourde que
celle des bimoteurs à l'heure en service
la troisième enfin été pour un
bombardier moyens lourds au zèle médiane
et seulement deux moteurs mais à la
différence de ses prédécesseurs fait de
bois et de toile
ce nouvel avion devait être métalliques
la menace d'une nouvelle guerre se
précisant il était temps pour cette
aviation de profiter de ces nouvelles
modifications structurelles pour faire
évoluer sa propre administration
ceux-ci se traduisit par la division de
la rfm commandement séparés en fonction
de leur mission
un commandement chargé de l'entraînement
fut formé tandis que les groupes
opérationnels étaient séparés en
commandement chargé de la chasse du
bombardement et de la surveillance
côtière
il y avait également cinq commandements
outre-mer de plus moyen-orient
méditerranée inde
aden est extrême orient tous ces
commandements était sous la
responsabilité du chef d'état-major via
le conseil de l'air chaque commandement
contrôler des groupes régionaux lesquels
administrer leurs propres bases qui à
leur tour administrer leur escadron
c'est avec cette structure que la rfa
combattit pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale les bases de la rfa aérodrome
comme on les appelait alors était passé
de 52 à 138 le 1er septembre 1937 sur
cyril succéda à seurre edouard ellington
comme chef d'état major
il continua les plans de développement
puisque la menace de guerre se
renforçait confirmé en 1938 par
l'annexion de l'autriche par l'allemagne
avec l'assentiment de la population
mais ville chamberlain le premier
ministre de la coalition du gouvernement
britannique dans l'espoir de calmer la
situation
s'envola pour munich pour une conférence
avec hitler mussolini et daladier
il revint en angleterre avec une
déclaration devenus célèbres signé par
les quatre dirigeants et est supposé
garantir la paix pour un long moment
bien peu de gens en étaient convaincus
mais ceci donne un peu de temps pour que
le programme de développement puisse
continuer il n'avait en effet pas encore
atteint un niveau satisfaisant le rythme
s'accéléra avec l'apparition d'un
nouveau commandement celui des ballons
de barrage
le corps féminin de la rff est également
créé la pire crainte du peuple anglais
survint lorsque les allemands envahirent
la pologne le 1er septembre 1939
deux jours après que hitler eut refusé
de répondre aux ultimatums français et
anglais la guerre était déclarée
en septembre 1939 la puissance de la rff
était de 1476 avions en angleterre et
435 stationnées outre mer ainsi que de
118000 mobilisés et 60000 réservistes
comparé aux 3600 avions de la luftwaffe
et à ses cinq cent mille hommes
la confrontation s'annonce est rude pour
la r f
en plus de cette formidable opposition
la luftwaffe comprenait cinq cent mille
autres soldats en charge de la défense
antiaérienne à l'ouverture des
hostilités le bon beurre commandes sous
la direction de l'artiste marchal sur
loup de l'eau et oui tu rassembles à 33
squadron constitué de wellington de
wheatley de hampden de bling et le ferry
bateau 10 d'entre eux furent envoyés en
france pour faire partie de la force de
frappe de première ligne en angleterre
l'escouade en restant n'était pas
considéré comme capable d'effectuer une
offensive de bombardements efficace
contre l'allemagne on leur donna deux
directives par l'intermédiaire du
cabinet de guerre
les seuls engagements militaires
viserait les navires de guerre et demi
en mer les autres missions s'en
tiendrait à des largages de tracts sur
les populations allemandes
ces missions de propagande débuter
immédiatement avec les squadron de
wheatley parfois épaulés par des
wellington
tout ça de nuit les raids de largage le
prospectus avait également démontré que
la rff était capable de voler
profondément à l'intérieur du territoire
ennemi aussi loin que berlin où viennent
mais il y avait un autre ennemi auquel
se confronte l arf
en plus de la défense aérienne allemande
un ennemi qui à les hanter le bon beurre
commande tout au long de la guerre
l'hiver les pertes étaient lourdes si
lourde en fait qu elles étaient
considérées comme inacceptables les
attaques du beurre commandes contre les
navires de guerre allemands dès le
lendemain de la déclaration de guerre se
résumait à une attaque menée deux jours
par dix blé name contre le croiseur de
poche admiral phone cher et le croiseur
emden bien que ce fût une attaque
courageuse elle ne donna rien et 5 des
bleus name furent perdues à cette époque
là et rêve pensait que pendant les raids
diurne menée par l'escouade run de
bombardier volant en formation serrée
contre des navires les mitrailleuses
donné de que de ses avions les rangs des
invités râble le résultat fut à l'opposé
les chasseurs ennemis escortant les
navires les abattent est en quantité en
moyenne 10 bombardier de la ras était
perdu pour quatre chasseurs allemands
descendu
le bon beurre commandes reconnu
rapidement la nécessité de disposer de
chasseurs d'escort à longue distance
si les bombardier devait continuer leur
est dû aux urnes mais il n'y en avait
pas encore de disponibles à ce moment de
la guerre le costume commandes entama la
guerre avec trois groupes ouest est et
écosse tout sous le commandement de la
chief marshal sur frédéric bovy
l'arsenal de ce commandement était
constitué de hansen loki datsun
d'origine américaine de vieux bombardier
torpilleur ville dort beeston de
sunderland london estrade reyers
l'ennemi c'est lé hub haute
le troisième des commandements
opérationnels de la r f était sous la
direction de leur chiffre marchal sur
young loading pendant les premiers mois
de la guerre le fighter commandes
s'étaient concentrés sur le renforcement
de ses escadrons on estimait que la
défense du territoire anglais
nécessitait au moins 53 squadron mais
elle avait commencé la guerre avec
seulement 35
ils étaient équipés de week-end de
spitfire et de gloucester gladiator pour
faire face aux exigences quelques
nouveaux squadron furent temporairement
équipés de blenheim et de battles afin
de satisfaire les besoins en équipage
nouveaux ont créé à l'amp bailleur
training chim avec le soutien du canada
de la nouvelle-zélande de l'australie de
la rhodésie de l'afrique du sud de la
pologne et de la tchécoslovaquie
juin 1940 hitler arrive sur les côtes de
la france défaite
il n'y a plus qu'un obstacle sur sa
route pour l'invasion de l'angleterre
la manche l'armée d'invasion dit claire
devait traverser cette barrière maritime
l'armée anglaise essayait de se
renforcer après ses lourdes pertes à
dunkerque
[Musique]
les hommes étaient démoralisés armes et
équipements avaient été abandonnés sur
place
la royal navy étaient éparpillés sur
toutes les mers du globe protégeant les
convois de navires des sous marins
allemands
la royal air force avaient été balayés
en france elle avait perdu 450 avions et
un nombre équivalent de pilote avait été
tué portés disparus ou faits prisonniers
hitler avait déclaré à son peuple que la
grande bretagne était une menace pour
l'allemagne
car la rff et la navy pouvait continuer
à combattre au début juillet il dévoile
à ses plans pour supprimer cette menace
et ordonna la préparation d'un assaut
aérien et naval contre l'angleterre pour
assurer à ses troupes une traversée
tranquille de la manche il leur donna à
la luftwaffe de détruire la chasse
anglaise pour établir la suprématie
aérienne la grande bretagne avec des
défenses affaibli se préparait à une
invasion imminente
[Applaudissements]
si la luftwaffe arriver à ses fins et
élimine l arf
toutes les tentatives de la royal navy
d'attaquer les barges de débarquement
sans couverture aérienne
la laisserai à la merci de la luftwaffe
et de la marine allemande le peuple
anglais retenait son souffle
et les premières attaques sur 20
des milliers de chasseurs et de
bombardiers allemands attaquent air lé
convoi naval dans la manche
[Musique]
les attaques eurent l'effet escompté
faire sortir la ras
[Musique]
la rfa riva face à la luftwaffe à 1
contre 10
les plans allemands consistait à tester
les défenses aériennes britanniques et à
l'obliger à puiser dans ces précieuses
réserves
les combats au dessus des convois
côtiers et ea après coûteux pour les
deux côtés mais les pertes allemandes
étaient plus importantes
[Musique]
hitler avait sous-estimé la ténacité
féroce des jeunes pilotes de la r f
il envoyait à ses bombardiers contre les
ports anglais de l'aco dessus
ce coin de l'angleterre commença alors à
ressembler un peu à l'envers
la luftwaffe continuer à subir de
lourdes pertes et bien qu'elles causent
à d'importants dommages aux convois
maritimes et au port ce n'était pas
suffisant pour stopper les
approvisionnent
la phase suivante fut de tenter de
clouer la chasse anglaise au sol en
détruisant les aérodromes et leurs
pistes mais la rfi était préparé bien
que les aérodromes était durement touché
de nombreux avions furent épargnés et la
rfa pu continuer le combat
un des avantages dont la sève disposait
était de combattre au dessus de son
propre territoire et de ses côtes
de nombreux pilotes descendu ayant
évacué leur avion en parachute ou
effectuer un atterrissage forcé était
capable de reprendre le combat sans
délai
la luftwaffe n'avait pas cette chance
ces pilotes aient été faits prisonniers
ou alors disparaissait dans la manche
quand leur avion était durement touchés
et qu'ils tentaient de regagner la
france
goering avait promis à hitler que ça
luftwaffe allait nettoyer le ciel
anglais des avions de la r f il
apparaissait alors que cette promesse
était loin d'être tenu il donne à de
nouveaux ordres à la luftwaffe
elle devait non seulement attaquer les
aérodromes mais s'en prendre aussi aux
zones industrielles dans une tentative
d'enrayer la machine de guerre anglaise
arf fut durement touchés mais en dépit
d'importants dégâts dans les usines la
production continuer
[Musique]
les pertes augmentait pour les deux
côtés
la rs avait souffert elle ne disposait
que de quelques centaines de chasseurs
par comparaison malgré de sévères pertes
la luftwaffe avait toujours plus de 2000
avions il devenait donc évident que
l'aer est ne pourrait pas tenir bien
longtemps mais là nous doit feu ne
connaissait pas la faiblesse de son
adversaire
car la résistance de la rs ne
faiblissait pas
[Musique]
en dépit des raids continuelles contre
les aérodromes il redevenait
opérationnel très rapidement
sans se rendre compte que la rfa tirait
en fait ses dernières cartouches
hitler commis une erreur incroyable il
ordonna de cesser les attaques contre
les aérodromes et de concentrer les
raids contre la plus belle cible londres
grâce à ce répit inespéré la rfi le
temps de se regrouper et de se réarmer
vague après vague les bombardiers
allemands écrasé les villes sans défense
mais la pression n'était plus sur les
aérodromes de la r f
le 15 septembre au paroxysme de la
bataille des formations massive de
bombardiers allemands surgir sur les
écrans radars alors qu'il traversait la
côte vers londres
là et rêve fut alertée
dans une zone qui faisait 100 km de long
60 km de large et 8 km de haut ont eu
lieu l'une des batailles les plus
décisifs de l'histoire
[Musique]
la rs relever le défi de la luftwaffe et
langage a à peu près tous ces chasseurs
disponibles bien que dominés dans un
rapport de force 2 1 contre 6 les
pilotes anglais volèrent et combattirent
sans relâche la horde des bombardiers
chasseurs à croix noire
ce fut une des heures les plus sombres
de l'angleterre
mais ce fut un des tournants de la
guerre le 12 octobre ils claire porta
définitivement son plan d'invasion
l'angleterre était pour le moment
sauvé
les raids continuèrent pourtant nuit
après nuit jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
mais la puissance grandissante de la rff
était la garantie qu hitler ne serait
plus jamais en position d'envahir
l'angleterre pendant la bataille
d'angleterre
seuls les pilotes de la r f s'était
interposé entre l'angleterre et les
nazis
un des plus légendaires de ces héros fut
douglas bader un personnage
impressionnant qui avait perdu ses deux
jambes dans un accident d'avion avant la
guerre
en dépit de son handicap c'était un
homme doté d'un sacré caractère
il parvint par sa seule volonté à
imposer à la et rêve de le laisser voler
lorsque la guerre commença il fut promu
flight lieutenant au 222e squadron
lorsqu'ils revendiquent à sa première
victoire aérienne en descendant un
messerschmitt 110 au dessus de dunkerque
en juillet 1940 il reçu le commandement
du 242e squadron une unité démoralisé
composé principalement de pilotes
canadiens ayant évacué la france
maeder avait des idées précises sur les
tactiques de combat et réussit souvent
imposer ses idées au ministère de l'air
une de ces idées étaient qu'on a infligé
de plus lourds dommages aux bombardiers
allemands en employant deux plus
importantes formations de chasseurs
ceux-ci entraîna de chauds débats entre
mallory et le commandant du onzième
groupe caspar
en septembre 1940 sa théorie fut mise en
pratique et les formations big wings
devint rapidement une procédure standard
pendant la bataille d'angleterre il
était constamment en commande de
formation importante de week-end et le
spitfire qui infligèrent de lourds
dommages à l'aîné
m'avait reçu alors la ds au pour sa
bravoure
dès le début de sa carrière bader avait
été énoncé quelques préceptes important
pour les pilotes de chasse au combat
[Musique]
devait piqué dans les formations et demi
pour tenter de les disperser et toujours
avec le soleil dans le dos ne jamais
suivre en aucune circonstance un
appareil ennemi endommagée pour
l'achever
car c'était devenir à son tour une cible
pour les chasseurs adverse
un avion isolé est une cible facile
le concept de bad heures fonctionner et
rapidement lima laurie commencent à
appeler le 242 squadron l'escadron des
désintégrateur
en octobre 1940 hitler reporte à
l'invasion de l'angleterre et sans prix
aux villes anglaises
à ce moment bader comment des cinq
squadron
en mars 1941 il fut promu queens
commandeur et devint l'un des premiers
wind leader
il remporta de nombreuses victoires au
dessus des côtes françaises
le 9 août il remporta la dernière il
venait juste de descendre de
messerschmidt 109 lorsque son avion fut
attaquée et touchée
son avion en flammes il sauta perdant
ses deux jambes artificielles dans
l'action
il se posa en territoire ennemi et fut
fait prisonnier immédiatement
anecdote amusante les allemands
donnèrent par radio l'autorisation à un
avion anglais de se poser en allemagne
pour apporter de nouvelles jambes abad
heures
mais la rfa opta pour une autre méthode
et profita d'un raid de bombardiers pour
larguer d'un blé naïm les deux jambes
artificielles
bader interné dans un camp de
prisonniers de guerre tenta de s'évader
il fut repris et après plusieurs autres
tentatives il fut enfermé dans la
forteresse de kohl dit quand spéciale
pour forte tête
il y demeura jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
libéré le 14 avril 1945 il retourna en
angleterre où il fut promu group captain
et commanding officer de l'école de
chasse de tighmert lorsque la rff
effectué à son défilé aérien au dessus
de londres pour célébrer la victoire
bader étaient à bord de l'avion de tête
il fut l'un des plus grands personnages
de la guerre est un des plus brillants
leaders de la rs
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale la rs
ne fit pas qu'apporter une formidable
contribution à la victoire
elle participa également au
développement des avions et de la
technologie de la violence
les premiers bombardiers lourds bimoteur
furent remplacées par des quadrimoteur
puissant et le sterling
le halifax et le superbe lancaster
[Musique]
de nombreux avions utilisés par les
combattants de la seconde guerre
mondiale devint célèbre mais bien peu
étaient vraiment grand cette grandeur
est une qualité qu'on ne peut pas de
toute pièces installées à bord sur un
plan ou sur les lignes d'assemblage un
grand avion doit posséder cette touche
de génie qui transcende et par dessus
tout de la chance la chance d'être à la
bonne place au bon moment il doit faire
preuve de qualités de vol au dessus de
la moyenne
la fiabilité la solidité et des
capacités à combattre touche finale il
nécessite le petit plus apporté par les
équipages le havre au lancaster avait
tout ça et bien plus son élégance donner
du plaisir à le regarder voler et son
aérodynamique soignée participer à ses
remarquables performances
[Musique]
comme sur de nombreux avions la base de
sa conception était simple sa structure
robuste était conçu idéalement pour la
fabrication industrielle et ce fut
indubitablement un des facteurs
principaux de son succès c'était
également un bombardier remarquablement
polyvalent et de tous les grands
meetings avion de la seconde guerre
mondiale beaucoup pensent qu'il était le
plus grand
la charge de bombes du lancaster était
impressionnante six mille trois cents
kilos en opération normale mais avec
quelques modifications
ils pouvaient emporter la bombe grand
slam de 10 tonnes quatre moteurs merlin
fabriqué par packard d' équipe est le
puissant bombardier lui donnant une
vitesse maximum de 430 km heure à 6000 m
le légendaire bamber harris commandant
du beurre commandes estima qu'il fut
sans doute le plus important des
bombardiers de la guerre à la fois par
ses performances et parce qu'il pouvait
être incroyablement chargés de bombes
sans qu'il ne se brise mais non
seulement ils emportaient de très
lourdes charges de deux bombes
mais il restait à ces manoeuvres ans il
avait également un taux de perte plus
faible que n'importe quel autre
bombardier et c'est sans doute la raison
principale de sa popularité auprès des
équipages
il y eut aussi des lancaster modifiées
capables d'emporter la bombe des raids
anti barrages l'oeuvre de barnes wallis
la bomba ricochet on a été les premiers
arrivés bien avant les autres on a
largué les mines elles ont explosé dans
une grande gerbe d'eau comme on s'y
attendait le sommet du barrage s'est
fissurée et de l'eau commençaient à
passer au travers
il y avait des voitures sur la route qui
ont commencé à être submergés dit que
c'était bon on pouvait rentrer à la base
et nous avons pris le chemin du retour
sur les dix neuf avions du raid de avait
dû faire demi tour suite à des problèmes
techniques
oui nous en avons perdu vite ce qui est
vraiment beaucoup
c'est aussi à cette époque qu'un autre
formidable avions fit ses débuts qui
prouve à être un combattant vital pour
la rs grâce à ses capacités multi rôles
nombre des avions les plus importants de
l'histoire sont nés non pas du résultat
d'une spécification officiel bien
inspiré mais en raison de la conviction
inébranlable d'un homme ou d'un groupe
d'individus pour une idée
révolutionnaire
il n'y a pas de meilleur exemple que le
de havilland mosquito qui s'éloigne a
bien loin des spécifications officielles
pendant le temps de sa conception pour
aboutir en un magnifique appareil
peut-être le meilleur de tous avec la
menace d'une guerre proche
les ingénieurs de de havilland
réalisèrent que l'industrie sidérurgique
mais aucune ne récompenser autant que
celle que reçu cheshire peut être l'un
des soldats les plus courageux de la
guerre sa carrière a commencé en juin
contre les cibles terriblement défendu
il démontra le courage et la
détermination d'un chef exceptionnel il
était toujours partant pour accepter des
risques supplémentaires afin d'assurer
le succès d'une mission défiant le
formidable système de défense de la ruhr
il larguer ses banques généralement à
une altitude plus basse que celle
recommandée uniquement pour obtenir de
meilleurs résultats contre sa cible au
dessus de cologne en novembre 1940 un
obus anti aériens touche à son avion
causant de nombreux dommages et même un
début d'incendié chercheurs continuent à
bombarder à sa cible est retourné à sa
base
en 1943 il prit le commandement du
légendaire 617e squadron et commença son
quatrième tour d'opérations com -
commandeur son impact sur l'unité est
directement la conséquence de l'étude
qu'il mena sur une nouvelle tactique
destinée à infliger des dégâts
significatifs sur des cibles de petite
taille il inaugurera un nouveau système
de marquage de cible en utilisant un
avion marqueur qui précédait la force
principale mais à plus basse altitude
le nouveau système de cheshire a
coïncidé avec le développement de la
bombe de douze mille livres
le premier raid fut menée contre les
usines aéronautiques de limoges le 8
février
técher menacé 12 lancaster à travers les
nuages atteignant sa cible au clair de
lune
dans l'avion de tête cheshire des 110 à
200 pieds au dessus de lusine et largue
à ces bombes incendiaires
en brûlant elle diffusait une intense
lumière rouge
les autres bombardiers derrière à 7000
pieds avait désormais un point précis
avisés et le raid fut un succès complet
chercheurs compris rapidement qu'il
était urgent de marquer les cibles avec
un avion plus rapide et plus manoeuvrant
que le lancaster
[Musique]
ce n'était qu'un de ses nombreux
exploits il a commandé le 617e squadron
pendant une quarantaine de raids son
engagement total et son leadership
indéniable n'avait d'égal que son
inventivité
il ne se reposait que sur son propre
jugement et les événements prouvèrent
qu'il avait raison mission après mission
au total il a mené sans mission est cent
fois il est parti à larguer ses bombes
affronter la flaque combattu sa propre
peur ça fatigue et le froid fait parler
son habileté et son ingéniosité pour
toujours regagner sa base il se
consacrait entièrement commandement de
son escadron devenant un exemple de
courage et de sang froid pendant tous
les combats bombardant et mitraillant
l'ennemi sans répit
afin de marquer cet engagement et cette
détermination ce courage sur une si
longue période
laura georges lui accorda une troisième
des haies saut et une victoria cross
la citation disait le wing commandeur
cheshire conduisit son escadron en
personne à chaque occasion
prenant toujours lui même les risques
les plus importants speedfan le spitfire
et les américaines ont été déclinées en
de nombreuses versions en dehors du
formèrent la colonne vertébrale du
fighter commandes jusqu'à ce que de
nouveaux avions viennent les épauler
le typhon et le tempest ce ne furent pas
les seuls avions que la rfi utilisa dans
le cadre du plan de l'église
les usa fournir une grande variété
d'avion le curtis p40 le thunderbolt
corsair l'avenger le rco bras levés
natura et le formidable mustang le bon
beurre commandes pris livraison du
mitchell du maraudeur du boston et du
liberator le coastal commandes reçues
des catalina et de hudson et sur les
champs de bataille la rfi utilise à
l'indispensable dc3 dakota
tepa afin de donner un aperçu complet
des activités de la r f pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale une bibliothèque
complète ne suffiraient pas et des films
tels que celui ci ne peuvent que tenter
de résumer en quelques minutes dans
l'importance de ses exploits et ce n'est
pas rendre suffisamment justice au
formidable chapitre écrit dans
l'histoire de la rfm plus important
encore nous devons rendre justice aux
dizaines de milliers d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont perdu la vie en écrivant
cette histoire on dépit que la rff et
perdu de nombreux jeunes hommes et
jeunes femmes courageux en particulier
ceux qui eurent la malchance de
rejoindre le banc de leur commande
ils furent toutefois plus nombreux à
survivre certains de justesse quand vous
êtes à bord d'un chasseur et que vous
êtes touchés et qu'il prend feu le
cockpit est envahi par les flammes en
quelques secondes
quand un bombardier prend feu ne faut
pas longtemps pour que le réservoir
fasse de même de nombreux aviateurs ont
souffert d' horribles brûlures pendant
la guerre une association a formé un
pont entre eux et nous les membres du
club des cochons d'inde
on dit que le courage n'est de
l'adversité ces hommes en ont retiré une
plus grande force
en dépit des blessures apparentes qu'il
ait des figures
une force qu'ils peuvent montrer
fièrement à la nation une force qui est
aussi un rappel du courage et de la
détermination de la r f
[Musique]
resté seul c'est très dur mais n'oubliez
pas que les membres du dîner apic clubs
qui sont passés par l'hôpital sont
nombreux et quand on est ensemble tous
ces vieux jeunes hommes qui ont tous le
sens de l'humour on s'entraide
car comme ça on fait face à l'adversité
car on y puise notre force nous ferons
une gestuelle et ça marche
la plupart de ces hommes ont réussi leur
vie là où on s'attendait à ce qu'ils
échouent je pense que ça nous apporte
une valeur fondamentale doit le respect
[Musique]
après la seconde guerre mondiale est
apparu comme peut-être la première force
aérienne au monde
pas forcément en taille bien qu'elle ait
atteint des totaux ahurissant mais comme
une armée de l'air ayant surmonté ses
adversaires sur passer elle même aux
yeux du monde la période d'après-guerre
aller voir naître un nouveau type de
puissance aérienne les règles de la
guerre aérienne allait être réécrites
plusieurs fois dans les années qui ont
suivi
[Musique]